People have been telling dogs to “sic ’em,”
with the intent to have the dog attack individual(s),
since at least the nineteenth century.
While this may seem odd given common modern
definitions for “sick” or the variant
“sic,” at the time this command popped
up, it made perfect sense.
“Sick,” in this context, had nothing to
do with the word meaning “ill,” but rather
was simply a dialectal variant of “seek,”
which used to sometimes carry the connotation
of seeking with the intent to attack.
(This sense of the word “seek” was used
as far back as around AD 1000 in the work,
Beowulf.)
The first known instance of someone instructing
a dog to attack someone using this “sick”
command occurred in Johnson J. Hooper’s
1845 Adventures of Capt. Simon Suggs:
You may well say that: what I tells them to
do they do—and if I was to sick them on
your old hoss yonder, they’d eat him up
afore you could say Jack Roberson.
And it’s jist what I shall do, if you try
to pry into my consarns…
And later in that same work,
“Here, Bull!” shouted the widow, “sick
him, Pomp!” but we cantered off, unwounded,
fortunately, by the fangs of Bull and Pomp,
who kept up the chase as long as they could
hear the cheering voice of their mistress—“Si-c-k,
Pomp—sick, sick, si-c-k him, Bull—suboy!
suboy! suboy!”
As to how that became such a popular way to
tell a dog to attack, rather than to simply
say “attack,” or something similar, this
isn’t known but makes sense given the types
of sounds dogs are able to pick out most easily
from normal human speech.
(Think when you hear someone speaking a foreign
language, it can at times just sound like
a jumble of random sounds.)
Thus, when training a new dog (and a young
child), most experts recommend “short, sharp
commands.”
“Sic” certainly fulfills these requirements,
being only one syllable and bookended by distinct
sounds.
And while the “s” part of the word may
seem to be a soft sound to human hearing,
perhaps easily drowned out in some circumstances,
dogs hear not only much better in range of
frequencies than humans, but thanks to quite
a bit of their brains being devoted to sounds,
they are also better at discriminating between
noises.
So something like a “ssssss” sound ends
up being relatively easy to pick out from
other human language to start a command, at
least more so than something like an “ah,”
and the hard “k” sound at the end is easily
distinguishable to finish it.
Sic is also used to denote when someone has
made a mistake.
This is often seen in print where a person
being quoted has made a grammatical or typographical
error, and the quote-r puts the quote in as
written (but includes  so that it is
clear that the quote-e made the mistake).
This use of sic has Latin origins, where it
literally meant, “so, thus, in this way;”
it traces its regular use in English to the
late 19th century.
Sick with the modern meaning of “excellent,”
“awesome,” or “very impressive,” according
to the OED, dates surprisingly far back, to
1983 in boarding (skate and snow) culture.